ich grüße sie herzlich vier jahre arbeit
haben sich gelohnt und vier jahre arbeit
liegen jetzt wieder vor ihm vor barack
obama sternstunden morgen hier bei
unserem sonntag danach wir schauen heute
unter anderem dorthin wo es aktuell noch
immer brennt in der welt syrien vom
bürgerkrieg zum krieg zwischen den
religionen eine einschätzung des nahost
kenners michael lüders
ich darf nicht länger schweigen sagte
sich der katholische theologe david
berger und outete sich als schwuler ein
filmporträt verliert sie das hobby heißt
die jüngste büchner-preisträgerin sie
redet von fantasie kindern und wundern
und über das geschenk der sprache die
modernen kreuzritter stehen im zentrum
der zweiten folge von amerika in
primetime der dokumentation über us
fernsehserien die neuen helden sind
keine saubermänner mehr
[Musik]
seit fast 20 monaten schon herrscht in
syrien ein erbitterter bürgerkrieg ein
krieg der übrigens längst eskaliert ist
so ein religiös motivierten krieg der
feind wird neuerdings auch an seiner
religion gemessen sunniten schiiten
aleviten christen sie alle bilden den
religiösen rahmen eines tödlichen
disasters wird syrien beherrscht von
einem religion seinem gottes krieg was
genau geht dafür warum und mit welchen
auswirkungen auf die nachbarländer
der islamwissenschaftler michael lüders
ist als nahost experte ein gefragter
mann weil er in damaskus studiert und
lange auch in arabischen staaten gelebt
hat hans schulz hat ihn zum gespräch
eingeladen
michael lüders in dieser woche sind zwei
welt politische entscheidungen getroffen
worden die eine den usa der präsident
wurde bestätigt die andere in china die
neue führung wurde bestimmt nun sind
beide akteure in syrien die einen
unterstützen die rebellen die anderen
unterstützen die regierung glauben sie
dass jetzt ein bisschen bewegung mit der
neuen führung in dieses starre front
hineinkommt das wäre sehr zu hoffen aber
es gibt wenig hinweise darauf dass wir
die amerikaner oder die chinesen sich
wirklich bewegen könnten
es wird wahrscheinlich eine fortsetzung
der verteilten rollen geben wie wir das
im letzten monaten gesehen haben
auf der einen seite die usa die
westlichen staaten die golfstaaten die
türkei die die rebellen in syrien
unterstützen und auf der anderen seite
russland china und der iran
die auf seiten der syrischen regierung
stehen das alles ist eine tragische
situation für die syrische bevölkerung
es wird sicherlich im nächsten jahr eine
lösung oder den ansatz einer lösung
geben geben müssen damit dieser konflikt
nicht zu einem regionalen konflikt wird
aber wie die lösung aussehen könnte das
steht gegenwärtig in den sternen
also sie reden auch von einer hoffnung
die aber sehr weit noch weg ist sie
kennen ja herr lüders damaskus sehr gut
die syrische hauptstadt sie kennt sie
aus besseren tagen muss man sagen sie
haben in den 80er jahren dort mal
arabische literatur studiert haben dort
gelebt
wie haben sie sich damals aufgenommen
gefühlt in der stadt ich hatte den
eindruck sie sehr oft finde statt
ja in der tat ist es eine sehr offene
stadt die menschen sind sehr freundlich
sehr gastfreundlich sehr zugewandt
damals war syrien noch stark
sozialistisch orientiert in der zeit des
kalten krieges da noch der vater erst
dran in der tat da war noch hafis al
assad der vater des jetzigen präsidenten
und diktators an der macht und damals
auch schon gab es machtkämpfe
ich erinnere mich dass einmal panzer
rollten durch damaskus weil ein cousin
des damaligen präsidenten versucht hatte
zu putschen er wurde daraufhin
abgeschoben und lebt seither in paris im
exil auf jeden fall waren die
verhältnisse in syrien immer instabil
die menschen sehr freundlich sehr
zugewandt damaskus ist eine der
schönsten städte im orient man kann
wirklich noch eine vorstellung bekommen
2000 einer nacht in den basar straßen
der altstadt es ist wunderbar aber im
augenblick natürlich haben diese oder
andere sorgen die meisten versuchen sich
mit den verhältnissen zu arrangieren
aber das ist kaum möglich dann ganze
städte sind mittlerweile mehr oder
weniger vollständig zerstört vor allem
in zentral syrien und viele syrer haben
natürlich die flucht ergriffen keiner
weiß wie es weitergeht und das schlimme
ist eine neutrale haltung einzunehmen
wie das zum beispiel die religiösen
minderheiten die christen die drusen
versucht haben den letzten monaten wird
immer schwieriger weil beide seiten
regierung wie auch die rebellen setzten
die minderheiten unter druck sich für
die jeweils als richtig empfunden seite
zu bekennen und für die regierung oder
für die reben einzustehen und wer das
nicht tut der riskiert entführt zu
werden oder gar umgebracht zu werden
also innerhalb von relativ kurzer zeit
ein völliger dreh insgesamt früher kamen
doch die religionen und ethnien und so
eigentlich ganz gut miteinander oder
wenigstens auch nebeneinander aus und
dann eigentlich innerhalb dieser letzten
20 monate hat man den eindruck hat sich
gedreht und man schlägt sich die cat
verein ja in der tat das hängt
wesentlich damit zusammen dass syrien
wie viele staaten des arabischen nahen
osten sehr stark geprägt sind durch die
jeweilige ethnische und religiöse
zusammensetzung wir erinnern uns in der
kolonialen geschichte hat man sich ja
nie interessiert aus sicht der franzosen
aus sicht der briten
grenzen gezogen haben der region nach
dem ersten weltkrieg für die wirkliche
zusammensetzung der bevölkerung man hat
grenzen irgendwo gezogen und dieselben
stämme dieselben kleine dieselben
familien fanden sich nun in
unterschiedlichen staaten wieder der
libanon zum beispiel das westliche
nachbarland syriens existiert überhaupt
nur weil es den franzosen in 1930 er
jahren gefiel
ein start für die christen einzurichten
und vor diesem hintergrund spielt also
die religiöse oder ethnische
zugehörigkeit immer noch eine sehr große
rolle
das wurde in friedenszeiten überdeckt
aber wir wollen nicht vergessen dass in
syrien eine minderheit nämlich die
religiöse gruppe der alawiten das ist
kann man vereinfacht sagen eine
schiitische sekte die macht ausübt aber
die mehrheit der bevölkerung stellen die
sunniten etwa 60 65 prozent der
bevölkerung und die alawiten haben in
der vergangenheit sich anderen
minderheiten gegenüber vor allem den
christen und den rosen sehr tolerant
gezeigt weil man ja selber eine
minderheit ist und haben es gleichzeitig
verstanden sich vor allem mit dem
sunnitischen bürgertum der reichen und
einflussreichen kaufmann schicht in
aleppo und in damaskus zu verbünden man
hat miteinander gute geschäfte gemacht
und so gab es eine art friedlicher
koexistenz die aber nur in
friedenszeiten bestand hatte jetzt wo
die staatliche ordnung zerbrochen ist
und wo der bürgerkrieg immer mehr
entlang ethnischer und religiöser
grenzen verläuft ist natürlich die frage
der zugehörigkeit eine sehr
existenzielle und das taten dann ein
tattoo an der falschen stelle
beispielsweise oder ein christliches
kreuz dass man allzu sichtbar trägt kann
das todesurteil bedeuten wenn man in
einer straßenkontrolle gerät die
sozusagen von den falschen leuten
besetzt ist also der nachbar wird
plötzlich zum feind nur weil er eine
andere religion hat oder weil man selber
eine andere religion hat muss man jetzt
nicht so ein bisschen vorstellen weil
das doch jetzt sehr weit weg ist für uns
wie in den 30er jahren zb in berlin
da wusste man gar nicht der nachbar ist
ein jude aber plötzlich spielte das eine
bedeutung weil einfach die ideologie
sich plötzlich geändert hat ja das ist
ein sehr interessanter vergleich den sie
da ziehen in der tat man muss es wohl
ein bisschen so sehen
auf einmal wenn es politisch so gewollt
ist spielt die religiöse zugehörigkeit
oder die volkszugehörigkeit eines
menschen eine ganz wesentliche
alle und dann wenn der staat
zusammenbricht wie das in syrien der
fall ist oder wie wir das im irak
gesehen haben nach dem sturz von saddam
hussein
dann ist es auf einmal zumindest aus der
sicht radikaler kräfte
ganz entscheidend ob der nachbar zonid
ist oder schied und es gilt so ein
bisschen die gleichung willst du nicht
mein bruder sein schlag ich dir den
schädel ein
und genau nach diesem prinzip
funktioniert mittlerweile der
bürgerkrieg in syrien
ursprünglich war das eine volkserhebung
vor allem ärmere sunniten in syrien
gegen die anmaßungen und zumutungen des
syrischen regimes das sich als unfähig
erwiesen hat das land in die zukunft zu
weisen und den menschen vor allem den
jugendlichen schülern eine perspektive
mit blick auf jobs und einkommen zu
geben aber diese volkserhebung ist
längst überlagert worden von einem
stellvertreterkrieg auf der einen seite
die westlichen staaten auf der anderen
seite russland china und iran die das
regime unterstützen was die syrer wollen
darum geht es längst nicht mehr
und die große gefahr ist eben dass je
länger dieser krieg in syrien dauert
umso mehr wird der zentralstaat zerstört
werden und umso größer wird der einfluss
werden von lokalen kommandanten von
warlords von kriminellen die im namen
irgendeiner ideologie oder allein aus
einer kriminellen motivation heraus
morde begehen in führungen
vergewaltigungen verursachen und begehen
das alles ist für die schüler sehr
dramatisch und es gibt offenbar keine
instanz die diese entwicklung aufhalten
könnte
es gibt ja immer wieder stimmen die
sagen was dort mittlerweile stattfindet
ist auch ein religionskrieg würden sie
so weit auch gehen es ist nicht ein
religionskrieg in dem sinne dass jetzt
es um fragen der religiösen identität
oder der auslegung religiöser schriften
gehen würde
es ist vielmehr ein politischer konflikt
eine machtfrage die sich hier
militärisch entlädt die aber zunehmend
entlang religiöser zugehörigkeiten
ausgefochten wird die sunniten gegen die
alawiten die christen in der hoffnung
irgendwie zu überleben die dosen
ebenfalls aber man weiß eben nicht in
welche richtung sich das entwickelt dann
kommen noch andere identitäten hinzu im
norden syriens gibt es kunden die
ethnisch gesehen keine araber sind das
alles ist also sehr komplex und es ist
auch ein hinweis darauf dass syrien wie
die meisten arabischen staaten in der
region eben noch
ein vormund der staat ist in unseren
europäischen staaten zumindest im
zentrum europas ist eher die frage wer
woher kommt eigentlich zweitrangig aber
in den ländern dort ist der familienname
möglicherweise schon ein hinweis darauf
was ich für eine geschichte habe ob ich
aus einer angesehenen familie einem
angesehenen klaren oder stamm komme und
das ist wesentlich für meine stellung
für meinen platz in der gesellschaft
kann aber auch für mich sehr gefährlich
werden wenn ich wie erwähnt in einer
straßensperre bei den falschen leuten
lande und wir leben gewissermaßen den
rückfall in vormoderne identitäten also
der weg syriens und viele arabische
staaten in eine moderne
industriegesellschaft ist blockiert seit
vielen jahren und jahrzehnten aufgrund
des unvermögens korrupte regime und
gleichzeitig entlädt sich eben die
gewalt auf eine sehr unguter art und
weise und ich kenne viele syrische
oppositionelle die mir gesagt haben wir
sind gegen dieses regime von baschar al
assad aber wenn wir gewusst hätten was
diese aufstand für folgen hat nämlich
die zerstörung syriens denn hätten uns
lieber mit baschar al-assad arrangiert
als durch ihn und die opposition unser
land zerstören zu lassen also es ist so
wie sie schildern nicht nur die
zerstörung die wir sehen im fernsehen
der häuser der ganzer städte sondern
auch die zerstörung von identitäten von
geschichte von von familien
sie haben gesagt also ein religionskrieg
in dem sinne ist es nicht und noch
einmal darauf zurückzukommen die
religion ist dann so etwas wie ein
brandbeschleuniger oder das öl das man
in die flamme gehst und sorgt dafür dass
es dann noch der konflikt noch heißer
entfacht wird ganz genau so kann man es
sehen
es ist auch so dass natürlich das
syrische regime unter baschar al assad
die ethnische karte ganz bewusst spielt
um die einen gegen die anderen
aufzuhetzen
aber es gibt eben darüber hinaus auch
sehr ungute entwicklung zum beispiel im
süden des landes in einem gebiet dass
hahn heißt in dieser region unweit der
jordanischen grenze gibt es viele dosen
es gibt dort aber auch viele christen
auch sunniten also eigentlich ein misch
eine mischung der syrischen gesellschaft
insgesamt seit beginn des aufstandes
sehen wir zunehmend eine entflechtung
der bevölkerungsstruktur das heißt in
einer überwiegend russischen gemeinde
ziehen die christen wegziehen die
sunniten weg
jeder geht zurück in seine eigenen
rückzugsgebiete und jeder jede
gruppierung versucht sich waffen zu
beschaffen nicht notwendigerweise am
bürgerkrieg teilzunehmen
aber man möchte gewappnet sein für den
fall dass irgendeine radikale miliz der
einen oder anderen seite das eigene dorf
überfällt man will sich nicht markieren
lassen und möchte sich verteidigen
können und das führt natürlich zu einer
unglaublich zerstörerischen dynamik
hinzu kommt die zerstörung der
wirtschaft es gibt eine rente
inflationsrate viele grundnahrungsmittel
auch öl zum heizen ist kaum noch
vorhanden also für die syrer ist das
wirklich eine katastrophale situation
viele sind geflüchtet hunderttausende
auch binnenflüchtlinge gibt es ist also
wirklich man kann sagen eine tragische
entwicklung syrien durchlebt das was
jugoslawien in den 1990 er jahren
ebenfalls durchlebt hat kommen wir noch
mal zu den einzelnen religionen sie
haben sie vorher schon alle benannt also
die alawiten das ist die religion der
herrscher im moment der der nicht nur
der führenden familie sondern auch der
übrigen herrsche clique sie haben sie
als eine islamische sekte bezeichnet was
ist denn so die grundüberzeugung der der
alawiten
es ist ganz interessant dass die
alawiten selbst eigentlich über keinen
religiösen kodex verfügen nicht über
heilige schriften auf diese referieren
würden man kann sagen das ist eigentlich
eine sehr pragmatische
religionsgemeinschaft diese alawiten in
syrien sind indirekt verwandt mit den
aleviten in der 33 kennzeichnend für
beide ist dass sie keine regulären
gotteshäuser kennen also die moschee an
sich ist ihnen weniger einen begriff man
kann gottesdienste überall abhalten in
privaten räumen und es bedarf keiner
besonderen theologischen ausbildung um
eine priester funktion ausüben zu können
es ist eigentlich eine moderne und sehr
tolerante religiöse ausrichtung des
canon übrigens auch hiervon von aleviten
die aus der türkei kommen und zum
beispiel ich wohne in basel in basel
gibt es relativ viele und sie sind
wirklich liberaler ich glaube auch in
sachen frauenrechte und so wesentlich
liberaler als die übrigen zehn schiiten
und sunniten absolut und die aleviten in
der türkei zum beispiel beklagen zu
recht dass sie sehr
unterdrückt werden von den sunniten die
mehrheits strömung in der türkei die
rolle der frau bei den aleviten ist sehr
viel entspannter als bei allen anderen
ein pflicht sich zu verschleiern oder
ein religiöses gebot oder tradition
dieses zu tun gibt es bei den aleviten
kaum oder gar nicht
es ist also wirklich eine sehr tolerante
religion aber in dem moment wo die macht
mit dem spiel kommt wie dies im falle
syriens der fall ist spielt religion
weniger eine rolle da gibt es dann mehr
geht es nur um eine gruppen identität um
eine klare identität es geht dann um die
verteilung der macht
es ist übrigens ganz interessant sich
anzuschauen wenn man sich mal den
inneren kern des alawitischen
machtzentrums anguckt in syrien dann
stellt man fest dass auf der ebene der
generalität es so gut wie keine reaktion
gibt in richtung ausland generäle sind
durchaus das ein oder andere mal
desertiert sunnitische generelle kein
alawitischen aber der innere macht kern
hält zusammen weil die alawiten
natürlich genau wissen wenn baschar al
assad regime stürzt dann wird es mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
massaker geben von radikalen sunniten an
den halle bieten und dafür hat man
natürlich große angst deswegen
verteidigt man die macht um jeden preis
das erklärt auch warum es in syrien
nicht möglich ist den weg ägyptens zu
gehen
dort hat ja die ägyptische armee
irgendwann mubarak als kriegsopfer dem
volk geopfert wenn ich so sagen darf
aber auf diese art und weise war
gewährleistet dass die armee im
hintergrund in syrien immer noch ihre
privilegien bewahren konnte und ist
weiterhin tut diese option gibt es für
syrien nicht wenn bascha al-assad
zurücktreten würde wenn er fällt wenn
seine clique sich nicht an der macht
halten kann dann werden die alle bieten
insgesamt wahrscheinlich einen
furchtbaren preis bezahlen für 40 jahre
unterdrückung die dieses regime der
syrischen bevölkerung angetan hat und
deswegen wird es sicherlich ein kampf
geben bis zum letzten schuss
also eine undurchschaubare verflechtung
von macht und religion dann gibt es die
christen die nehmen wir natürlich hier
bei uns besonders war auch weil sehr
viele christen flüchten vor allem reden
wie man dann schon geflüchtet sind sie
waren bisher eigentlich toleriert und
hatten relativ viele freiheiten woher
kommt das warum
konnten sich christen so frei dort
entwickeln zunächst einmal haben
natürlich die christen eine bis in die
zeiten jesu zurückreichende tradition in
der region sind bis zum siebten
jahrhundert war sie ihren eigentlich ein
christliches waren ganz genau und dann
auch im zuge der islamisierung sind die
christlichen gemeinden geblieben die
christen hatten immer einen guten ruf in
syrien der gegenwart im irak der
gegenwart weil sie vielfach als händler
aber auch als vermittler eine wichtige
rolle gespielt hatten und die alawiten
weil sie selber eine minderheiten
herrschaft darstellen waren natürlich
daran interessiert sich mit den anderen
minderheiten gut zu stellen
der deal war eigentlich immer wir lassen
euch in ruhe so lange ihr uns in ruhe
lasst ihr könnt in wirtschaftlicher
hinsicht tun was immer ihr zutun beliebt
ihr könnt geld verdienen können
geschäfte aufmachen was immer ihr wollt
aber stellt nicht die machtfrage sonst
geht es euch an den kragen egal ob man
christ ist rose oder sony
wer die machtfrage gestellt in syrien
landete im gefängnis oder wurde ein kopf
kürzer gemacht jetzt ist die lage der
christen sehr kompliziert es gibt
verschiedene christlichen gruppierungen
die alle der ostkirche angehören oder
zum überwiegendem überwiegenden mehrzahl
es gibt eine kleine gruppe von römischen
katholiken überwiegend aber
griechisch-orthodoxe christen und die
sind sehr gespalten in ihrer loyalität
zum regime
es gibt teilweise gebiete die von den
rebellen bereits kontrolliert werden
dort haben sich die christen den
rebellen angeschlossen aber da wo das
assad regime immer noch die macht ausübt
sind die christen loyal gegenüber diesem
regime aus gutem grund es ist ein
klassisches verhalten von religiösen
minderheiten
man möchte nicht in die situation
geraten massakriert zu werden das ist
eine reale gefahr
1860 also vor über 150 jahren hat es in
damaskus ein furchtbares massaker
gegeben von muslimen an christen und
dieses massaker obwohl es so lange
zurückliegt ist im kollektiven
bewusstsein der christen von damaskus
noch immer sehr sehr lebendig und man
hat geradezu panische angst davor dass
sich das wiederholen könnte deswegen
versuchen die christen zu lavieren
irgendwie zu überleben
aber es ist natürlich schwierig weil in
dem moment wo die anarchie ausbricht mit
autobomben
enthalten explodieren da nützt die beste
strategie nichts mehr da geht es nur
noch ums überleben
ein vorteil muss man sagen haben die
christen wenn sie sich ins ausland
begeben fliehen
dann haben sie größere chancen ein visum
zu bekommen um ein neues leben in kanada
usa oder australien zu beginn als die
muslime weil die christen eben doch uns
in vielerlei hinsicht näher stehen
zumindest in der wahrnehmung der pass
ausgebenden institutionen und das
erleichtert ihnen die emigration und die
flucht ins ausland
trotzdem unterstützt dass der
christliche westen also vor allem das
christliche amerika unterstützt die
rebellen die vor allem sunniten sind in
der tat es gibt hier viele widersprüche
die sehr erstaunlich sind vor allem auch
die tatsache dass saudi arabien der
maßgebliche finanzielle und militärische
unterstützer der aufständischen der
rebellen ist aus amerikanischer sicht
handelt es sich hier um eine
freiheitsbewegung bei diesen rebellen
aber saudi arabien ist nicht bekannt für
seine demokratischen tradition und
unterstützt natürlich auch nicht
reguläre kräfte sondern radikale
islamistische kräfte und das macht es ja
auch so schwer in syrien eine opposition
zu finden sind geeint wäre die
opposition ergibt ein heillos
zerstrittene bild es gibt verschiedene
milizen und gruppierungen die sich
teilweise auch untereinander bekämpfen
immer größeren einfluss gewinnen
radikale islamisten die aus dem ausland
ein gesichert sind vor allem aus dem
irak aber auch aus libyen afghanistan
und anderen ländern
und das wissen auch die amerikaner
deswegen sind sie dieser tage bemüht
während einer konferenz in katar den
syrischen nationalrat zu erweitern in
eine syrische nationale initiative mit
dem ziel einen ansprechpartner zu haben
hier versuchen die amerikaner aber die
quadratur des kreises sie wollen
möglichst eine säkulare opposition
unterstützen und finanzieren
aber die gibt es in syrien kaum denn der
widerstand ist islamisch islamistisch
motiviert und je offener die amerikaner
sich für eine bestimmte form der
opposition aussprechen umso größer ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass dieses zum
todeskuss für diese ausgewählte
gruppierung bedeutet denn der vorwurf
agent amerikas zu sein
ist für jede politische bewegung im
nahen osten im arabischen teil des nahen
ostens ein ein sicherer hinweis darauf
dass jede legitimation verloren ist also
eine wirklich fast zur verzweiflung
bringen de gemenge lage die sie da
leider schildern müssen irgendwann mal
zurückzukommen auf die 80er jahre als
sie in damaskus waren diese unterschiede
zwischen den religionen die sie uns da
gerade schon geschildert haben also auch
zwischen alawiten unteren christen und
und wer zu wem hält und so haben sie das
damals auch schon bemerkt oder war das
einfach das war halt so darüber hat man
gar nicht sprechen müssen im alltag hat
das überhaupt keine rolle gespielt es
gibt auch vielfach natürlich
eheschließung zwischen sunniten
beispielsweise und alawiten weniger
zwischen christen und muslimen das ist
eigentlich eher die ganz große ausnahme
gleichwohl wusste man ungefähr wer zu
welcher gruppe gehört weil die
stadtteile in damaskus sehr stark
ausgerichtet sind nach verschiedener
religiöser zugehörigkeit man wusste also
dass zum beispiel in der gegend von bad
tumor am rande der altstadt von damaskus
fast ausschließlich christen leben in
anderen vierteln wiederum muslime das
spielt im alltag nicht wirklich die
rolle aber es war halt bekannt und in
dem moment wo natürlich dann die
staatliche gewalt zusammenbricht dann
auf einmal haben die menschen keine
identität mehr und keine institution
mehr auf diese sich jenseits ihrer
unmittelbaren religionszugehörigkeit
berufen können und dann spielt das auf
einmal eine große rolle
das ist auch im libanon zu beobachten
gewesen wo die menschen friedlich
zusammenlebten und dann explodierte das
land in den 1980 er jahren das gleiche
im irak nach dem sturz von saddam
hussein es ist wenn man so will der
fluch dieser östlichen arabischen
gesellschaften dass ihr
modernisierungsprozess zu langsam
verläuft sie auf dem weg sind in
richtung industrialisierung moderner und
dienstleistungsgesellschaft aber auf dem
weg dahin fallen sie aufgrund des
zusammenbruchs der staatlichen ordnung
und der despotie der eigenen regime
zurück in vormoderne im feudalen
strukturen mit allem was dazugehört also
vielfach erinnern ja diese kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen in syrien im irak
im libanon die wir gesehen haben
ein bisschen an den dreißigjährigen
krieg in europa
wo wirklich auf das brutalste auf der
grundlage von religionszugehörigkeit
gekämpft wurde
aber natürlich übergeordnete
machtpolitische interessen eine rolle
spielten es ist also tragisch zu sehen
auf der einen seite haben wir aufbruch
in der arabischen welt und der
funktioniert in teilen auch ganz gut in
ägypten indonesien in libyen dann haben
wir aber bürgerkriegsähnliche
auseinandersetzungen in syrien im jemen
und dann haben wir regime die versuchen
den wandel aufzuhalten allen voran saudi
arabien und die ölstaaten am arabischen
golf am persischen golf die panische
angst davor haben von diesem virus der
freiheit und der modernisierung erfasst
zu werden äußerlich sind die golfstaaten
zwar sehr modernen ultramodernen von der
architektur her gesehen aber die
mentalitäten sind immer noch voll da als
staatlich geprägt also über saudi
arabien müssen noch mal wirklich reden
weil das ist ja die große regionalmacht
dort auch saudi arabien unterstützt die
sunniten sie haben vorher erwähnt dass
es die eigentliche mehrheit im lande die
war aber unterdrückt und versucht jetzt
mit gewalt so quasi an die regierung zu
kommen wäre dann so ein vorbild
eigentlich saudi arabien also würde
hinterher syrien wenn es dann gelänge
würde syrien dann ähnlich diktatorisch
regiert frauen haben überhaupt keine
rechte dürfen eigentlich nur durch einen
kleinen sehschlitz die welt begutachten
also das sind ja keine sehr schönen
aussichten dort für die menschen und
ausgerechnet wir unterstützen diese
gruppierung das muss man mal wieder
sagen das ist ja unsinnig
das ist in der tat ein großer
widerspruch und es war wahrscheinlich
auch ein fehler der westlichen staaten
einschließlich der türkei zu früh mit
dem regime von baschar al assad zu
brechen der mann ist natürlich ein
fürchterlicher schlechter seine eigene
bevölkerung aber er hat eben noch immer
die macht und dem man sich zu früh auf
seiten der rebellen gestellt hat hat man
jetzt das große problem was machen wir
eigentlich wenn baschar al-assad in zwei
drei jahren immer noch an der macht sein
sollte dieses dilemma hat vor allem die
türkei die hat sich eine spitze der
bewegung gesetzt der wahl die die
opposition unterstützen und nun droht
der krieg in syrien auch auf die türkei
überzugreifen
es ist also eine ganz gefährliche
situation wie es in syrien weiter geht
wissen wir heute nicht wirklich es gibt
zwei szenarien entweder syrien zerfällt
ähnlich wie jugoslawien
190 jahren zerfallen ist und es gibt
eine ganze gruppe von kleinen staaten
und städte leyen die kontrolliert werden
von kriegsfürsten oder von irgendwelchen
gruppierungen fragwürdiger couleur
oder aber es gibt weiterhin einen
zentralstaat syrien der würde dann aber
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit von
ultrakonservativen zu mieten
kontrolliert werden sich sehr stark an
saudi arabien ausrichten und das wäre
für die frauen in syrien beispielsweise
mit sicherheit keine positive
entwicklung das ist ein bisschen die
absurdität wir unterstützen im namen der
freiheit gruppierungen die eben nicht
die freiheit im sinn haben es geht aber
hier um geopolitik um nichts anderes
syrien ist das regime von baschar al
assad der wichtigste verbündete der
regierung des regimes in teheran und aus
amerikanischer sicht ist der sturz
dieses regimes von baschar al assad die
voraussetzung um die sogenannte
schiitische achse zu zerstören die von
teheran über bagdad damaskus bis zur
hisbollah der partei gottes in den
libanon reicht über damaskus erfolgt der
waffennachschub der hisbollah aus dem
iran
also die überlegung der amerikaner die
israelis und anderer ist stürzt dieses
regime haben wir diese achse geschwächt
deswegen soll baschar al-assad weg und
umgekehrt wissen natürlich die sau die
es ganz genau wenn die sunniten an die
macht kommen dann werden sie die
privilegierten beziehungen zu teheran
beenden und sich uns in saudi arabien in
riad zu wenden das ist gewissermaßen der
deal es ist wenn man so will ein ein
faustischen pakt denn für die menschen
in syrien würde die zuwendung zu einem
islamischen fundamentalismus aller saudi
arabien nicht eine verbesserung ihrer
lebensverhältnisse bedeuten sondern
eigentlich ein rückfall in die 50er oder
60er jahre
ja der iran sie haben gerade erwähnt sie
haben ihr letztes buch über den iran
auch geschrieben der iran spielt dort
als die andere regionale großmacht eine
rolle kann man auch sagen es ist
wirklich das wort stellvertreterkrieg
wir schon mal sagen schiitisch
sunnitische stellvertreterkrieg der da
auf syrischem boden stattfindet es sieht
immer mehr danach aus dass es genau
dieses wird ein stellvertreterkrieg
zwischen sunniten und schiiten aber eben
auch
neuer krieg zwischen den alten und neuen
regional und großmächten auf der einen
seite die usa auf der anderen seite
russland und china
und wie ich in meinem buch iran der
falsche krieg versucht habe zu
argumentieren es gibt natürlich die
große gefahr dass dieser konflikt
irgendwann auseinander
die ganze region auseinanderbrechen
lassen könnte dass es zu einem brand
kommt der eben vom iran über syrien bis
nach israel reichten die ganze region in
flammen setzt die alternative wenn man
das nicht will ist ist solide zu
verhandeln mit dem iran
die regierung obama die jetzt ein neues
mandat bekommen hat will ja dieses auch
tun bilaterale gespräche mit teheran
es bleibt abzuwarten ob das wirklich
dazu kommt oder ob das nur ein 1 1
offentlich kai zweck ist eine
ankündigung der aber keine taten folgen
wenn es nicht gelingt diesen konflikt zu
befrieden wenn es nicht gelingt sich mit
dem iran ins benehmen zu setzen
dann droht der region in der tat ein
großer klar wir müssen abwarten wie die
wahlen in israel ausgehen ende januar
wird die regierung netanjahu im amt
bestätigt wonach es aussieht bleibt die
frage wie verstehen sich die neuen und
alten regierungen in washington und in
israel
davon hängt es ab wie es weitergeht im
iran und in syrien es ist also
bemerkenswert zu sehen dass in dieser
region alles mit allem zusammenhängt man
redet über syrien und landet dann aber
auch in den usa
das ist die geopolitik und das ist die
tragik unter der die menschen dort auch
leiden ja da halten was sie jetzt
geschildert haben sie das nicht so aus
und zwar auf lange sicht nicht so aus
dass in nächster zukunft junger menschen
so wie sie vor 25 jahren mal in damaskus
studieren können junge menschen aus dem
westen
vielen dank erstmal michael lüders für
all diese informationen und für diese
komplexe auskunft die sie uns gegeben
haben
vielen dank
[Musik]
dieses gespräch finden sie natürlich
auch auf unserer website die dvd dazu
gibt es ebenfalls wenn sie schreiben am
schweizer radio und fernsehen redaktion
sternstunden 80 52 zürich ihre e mail
erreichte uns unter stern kopien hat sf
punkt ch fernsehen das ist heute längst
mehr als nur das flimmern am bildschirm
und deswegen empfehle ich ihnen schauen
sie uns auch online denn da bieten wir
ihnen viel zusatzmaterial zum beispiel
das gespräch mit dem syrischen jesuiten
nasa nur für den der aktuelle
bürgerkrieg ganz einfach alltag ist nun
zu einem ganz anderen thema von
kindesbeinen an ist er fasziniert von
der lateinischen messe von
althergebrachten riten und prachtvollen
barock gewändern er habilitiert den
katholischer dogmatik pflegt kontakt zu
katholisch konservativen kreisen wird
jüngster professor an einer päpstlichen
akademie dann das verdikt david berger
outet sich als schwuler und bekennt sich
zu seinem partner mit dem er seit über
20 jahren zusammenlebt
in seinem umstrittenen buch der heilige
schein kritisierte den umgang der
römisch-katholischen kirche mit
homosexuellen heftig seine kirchliche
karriere ist damit zu ende
sehen sie uns einen film